سمعنا خطاب بنيامين
نتنياهو
أنه يتجاهل
الفلسطينيين والمستقبل كليًا
وسيكون الجهد لتهميشهم
تمامًا من
خلال زيادة التواصل مع
الدول العربية الأخرى وخاصة السعوديين
وأعتقد أن هذه سياسة خطيرة
لأننا نعيش معهم معًا
أولاً.  من كل ما لدينا مليون ونصف
المليون عربي داخل إسرائيل ولكن لدينا
حوالي أربعة ونصف مليون في
الضفة الغربية وغزة
والتغاضي عنهم بالكامل هو دعوة
أممم لكن هناك أشياء أخرى
المحاربون
أه جزء منهم  هذه الحكومة
وخاصة القادمين الجدد من اليمين المتطرف
لا تدرك حقًا أن
العالم لا يعرف أن العالم لا
يقلق من
النقد النقد
الدولي وأعتقد أنه
يجب تقديم العالم إليهم ويجب على العالم
أن يتحدث علانية و  أخبرهم بما
يفكرون به بشأن هذه الحكومة الإسرائيلية الجديدة